minimizing and decluttering my home has
had a domino effect in many aspects of
my life
I began decluttering my home my wardrobe
my schedule and saying no to things that
I didn't want to do
spending my money and time more wisely
and being more intentional about my
purchases
decluttering is definitely an important
aspect of simplifying but it can often
feel overwhelming to think about what
areas of our life need simplifying so
today I will be sharing with you 25 tiny
ways to simplify your life and be sure
to stick to the end for my favorite one
and share your own tiny hacks for living
a simpler happier life starting off with
a couple of food related ones simplify
your meals have a few easy to make
favorite meals and then just alternate
the veggie or the protein this way
you'll feel like you're having something
different all the time but it's really
the main same ingredients and you'll be
much more likely to have these
ingredients on hand for example I love
to make carbonzo bean soup with carrots
sometimes I will use the garbanzos in a
stir fry sometimes I add a boiled egg to
the soup or I might drain them and use
them in a salad find some healthy
ingredients that you can make your own
Kitchen Essentials and just switch up
the way that you prep them this takes
meal prep to a whole nother level
because you're eating the same thing
every day without feeling like you're
eating the same thing use your freezer
batch prep your Basics and freeze a
portion immediately after cooling for a
lazy quick meal sticking with a garbanzo
example when I make a soup I freeze a
container to use later on so that I
don't always have to cook if we recently
had the soup and I don't feel like
cooking but I also don't want the same
thing I may just add some salsa some
spinach or some boiled eggs I love a
good freezer meal but just remember to
thaw either that morning or night before
if you have one use your slow cooker
slow cook meals when you're going up for
errands are going to work so that you
have food ready for when you get back
home many of our legumes and soups I
make this way because this way when I
leave to go to work and come back home
dinner is warm and ready with very
minimal effort wash your dishes
immediately after eating Rudy and I
don't have a dishwasher or a dish rack
and I did this on purpose when we moved
into this home one because I didn't see
a need for a dishwasher and two because
I didn't want an ugly dish rack staring
me in the face every day and taking up
room in our counters but by not having a
dishwasher it kind of forces us to deal
with our dishes immediately so usually
while I'm cooking I'll wash like the
bigger items and then after dinner we'll
wash them and I'll towel dry and put
them all away because I'm always on top
of this it really doesn't take but just
a few minutes it's often when we let the
mess pile up that things get a little
bit more complicated
so this simple habit can greatly help to
reduce your mess alright enough food
related tips take your shoes off inside
the house for me visitors are a
completely different thing I will never
ask a visitor to take their shoes off
when they're in my home because it's
very much a cultural thing but for our
family we definitely abide by this rule
this next one is also part of the reason
why I don't spend nearly as much time
keeping the floors clean as I used to
and it is to have a designated dirty
shoe for when you're going to be doing
messy activities or when it's just an
icky muddy rainy day a rain boot is
perfect for this but if you're like me
and you don't have one an old worn out
shoe will do just fine part of
simplifying our cleaning routines I
think is just preventing the mess to
begin with and tackling your shoe
situation is definitely a great way to
reduce the mess ditch your laundry
hamper or at least reduce the amount
that you have we don't have any dirty
laundry hampers anything that sturdy
immediately goes in the washing machine
and when it's full I wash and whites for
me are pretty easy because we rarely
wear white pretty much on purpose
because it's hard to keep white white
but for the few whites we have I wash
those with our Linens which I typically
wash separately anyway
have all the same kind of sock a couple
of years back I bought a pack of all the
same black socks because of this I never
have to worry about the lost loners or
finding a matching sock our kids also
have the same socks as well making it so
much easier because there's no sifting
to do not to mention all black socks
means no having to worry about icky sock
stains condense your undergarments I'm
definitely a plain Jane on this one I
alternate between the same two black
strapless bras because I don't have to
worry about straps showing this way and
I also have the same kind of underwear
with the exception of a couple of black
granny panties for period days because
it's all black everything matches and
it's something that I don't even have to
think about DIY your signature drink if
you have a signature drink that you
enjoy find a way to make it at home
obviously this can help you save money
and when you have Financial strain
saving money can definitely simplify
your life but even though it takes more
time to make it you actually end up
Saving Time unlike money time is that
resource you cannot make and this is
what simplifying is all about think
about it by the time you drive to the
Starbucks or whatever Place get in line
order wait for your drink pay and drive
to wherever you were going you could
have made a similar drink for a fraction
of the cost and if it matters to you
possibly even a healthier person we
purchased an espresso machine a year ago
because Rudy is very particular about
the taste of his espresso I use it all
the time to get hot water for my teas as
well as defrost milk for my beloved
lattes for me once I learned how to make
my favorite drinks at home I no longer
felt the desire to buy the store-bought
version order your groceries online two
of the grocery stores near me have
pickup options available and I love it
it has been game changing for me once
you've condensed your cooking to your
favorite items you'll have items that
you'll basically purchase on a regular
basis so what I love about this is that
I can just go to my history and reselect
the same items give or take a few things
then I just pull in and somebody else
has already thrown through the halls and
bagged them for me the places that I go
to don't charge anything extra for this
but it's also a way to help reduce those
random purchases out of curiosity or
distraction at the checkout line keep
only your favorites we make so many
decisions in a day from what to wear to
what road to take to the big decisions
like do I take this job or start this
project there's a thing called decision
fatigue which basically describes our
dwindling ability to make good decisions
as the day goes on because as the day
goes on we've already had to make tens
or hundreds of decisions often
completely irrelevant and unimportant as
an example if you have two coffee mugs
that are very similar but every day you
spend just a few seconds deciding which
mug to use pick your favorite and
consider getting rid of the other and
find as many situations in your home as
possible where you can get rid of the
alternate Choice an added bonus is that
everything you use will be your favorite
set night mode and do not disturb at
night I'm not going into detail on this
one because I have an entire playlist
devoted to having balance with our
technology but simplifying our time also
means setting boundaries and
prioritizing what matters to you if
you're used to being available 24 7 and
have had a pointless message wake you up
through the night make the decision
today to prioritize rest your body will
thank you immediately address mail as
soon as it enters the door of your home
scan it email it to yourself shred it
whatever you have to do but don't leave
it for later just piles a huge mess
you'll eventually dread tackling
and more likely procrastinate on as it
gets bigger I love this next one listen
to decluttering videos audiobooks or
podcasts while you clean or declutter
let me know in the comments am I the
only one that listens to these sort of
videos while cleaning or decluttering I
love to do this because often while I'm
going through my house and tidying I'll
often get an idea of something that I
can simplify in my own home and I find
it very motivating it is actually one of
the biggest reasons why I enjoy cleaning
my home because I've paired it with
something that I enjoy this is what
author James Clear calls habit stacking
in his book Atomic habits it's often
hard to know where to begin decluttering
or simplifying if you already feel
overwhelmed but by making it a pleasing
activity by pairing it with something
that you enjoy doing it makes it much
more likely that you'll keep up the
motivation improving your results beat
the Frog every day every day do one
thing that you dread doing but would
feel a whole lot better once you've
accomplished it scan those documents
that piled up take out that garbage
that's overflowing write that resume
that you're afraid to write or take that
cold shower to wake you up in the
morning and get you going eating the
frog is a great way to help develop
discipline and confidence as you
actually do the things that you've set
out to do sleep early or take naps it
can be really easy to try to push off
sleep in order to get things done but we
often end up less productive and less
creative the next day I have a video on
how I wake up at 5am that's packed full
of tips to help you go to sleep earlier
and wake up earlier and for me waking up
early is definitely my preferred for
productivity but I recently learned
about sleep chronotypes you can take a
free online quiz to find out what your
ideal sleep schedule is based on your
own body's natural tendency
unfortunately most employers will not
accommodate your preferred sleep
schedule but knowing how your body works
can help you create a better routine
unique for you let me know in the
comments are you a night owl or a
morning person quit using social media
to follow other people's lives there is
nothing quite more time sucking than
devoting our time to people that we
don't even know or truly care about and
failing to pay that attention to
improving our own lives if you use
social media for business or other
beneficial ways awesome but for most
people that tends not to be the case and
it often ends in a spiral of never
endless scrolling that accomplished
pretty much nothing schedule everything
if you're often laid or forget events or
important dates do yourself a favor and
download the free Google Calendar app
and schedule everything as soon as you
agree to it if you're at the dentist
scheduling your next visit schedule it
right there and then you'll never have
to rely on appointment reminder cards
and you'll seem like the master at
remembering birthdays because you can
add them directly to your contacts and
they load onto your calendar so the next
time you get an invite you can put
everything in and declutter those
invites and appointment reminder cards
write everything down I love journaling
I've definitely found it beneficial in
my life and it's something that truly
has helped improve my life I have a
video describing 10 different techniques
that you can use if you're a beginner at
it but if you're not quite ready to
start writing on paper just yet at the
very least use your notes app on your
phone sticky notes or heck even a napkin
to write down things that you want to
remember such as that recipe that you
made that actually turned out well or
that thing that you want to declutter
when you get home writing things down
makes my life so much easier eliminate
your TV or limit yourself to One Long
episode or movie per day if you love
your kdramas as tempting as it may be to
go on a binge when you're able to step
away and say that was enough no more
you're prioritizing your own health and
your own real life over that fictitious
life that you're submerging yourself in
in my video how quitting TV has changed
my life I share with you the real issues
that Rudy and I faced in our marriage
and the huge impact that it had on our
lives but if you don't find yourself
with a problem of addiction then maybe
having a simple house rule of just one
movie or one long episode just might be
the perfect balance declutter your
credit cards unless you use your credit
cards wisely for points and such
consider paring down your credit cards
to a select few I remember at one point
having several credit cards because
certain stores had discounts if you
purchased with a credit card but I found
that because of this I was buying items
that I wouldn't otherwise buy if I
didn't have these cards and then I had
the annoyance of having to remember to
pay these bills at different times I
eventually got tired of it and I
canceled all of my store credit cards I
don't negate that there are some awesome
ones out there for like travel rewards
and points but really just ask yourself
if your credit cards are serving you and
if not consider getting rid of them
automize your payments if you haven't
done this already you are missing out
Rudy and I have automatic bill pay on
everything that offers it it was always
a nuisance to have to log in and pay for
things unless say that after having kids
I lost my touch and we woke up to the
lovely surprise of not having phone
service once twice okay maybe a few
times I love that I don't have to think
about paying bills anymore automized
Savings in the same way that you want to
make paying your bills automatic your
savings should also be a priority so if
you have a recurring schedule that
you're paid in log into your bank
account and create automatic transfers
just like your employer pays you also
make the choice to pay yourself and
lastly my favorite is to have a capsule
wardrobe this is one that I don't feel
like I've quite curated yet I have a few
shirts that I rotate through but I don't
quite want to give myself the budget to
replace a few items just yet instead
what I've been doing is shopping my own
closet I've eliminated what I don't feel
good in even if they were expensive and
even if they're pretty
I used to keep things because they were
just pretty and I spent money on them
but if I'm not getting use out of them
someone else may the phrase if it's not
a hell yes it's a hell no can be a great
rule of thumb to help you create the
capsule wardrobe of your dreams so go
through your own closet and find your
favorites and eliminate the rest and you
just might find that doing this can
bring you so much more joy because this
way every day you're wearing your
favorite that's it for today's video if
you liked it please don't forget to give
it a thumbs up and help support my
channel also subscribe if you want to
see more content aimed at minimalism and
slow living and don't forget to share
your own simple living tips down in the
comments below so we can all learn from
each other I'll see you in the next one
bye for now